House Republicans once again trying to
hammer out a deal on immigration ahead
of the fall elections they feel that's
very important for some reason a current
draft proposal being considered by
Republican leaders is probably better
than prior proposals but it falls far
short of what the current president
campaigned on it would give amnesty to
some daca recipients in return it would
fund a border wall it says and the
diversity lottery and catch and relief
release and create a more merit-based
legal immigration system but it would
not end chain migration cut overall
immigration levels or critically
implement a verify to keep employers
from employing illegal aliens what to
make of this plan exactly Lou Dobbs is
of course the host of Lou Dobbs tonight
on Fox Business and maybe more than any
other person in public life has followed
this a bit carefully over more than a
decade Lou thank you for coming on what
do you make of this it's complex but I
know that you can cut to the heart of it
well let's cut let's cut through the
complexity because first of all we don't
know what's in it
there has been no debate there has been
no writing of text or amendments it is a
preposterous closed room deal entirely
drawn up by the speaker who is on lock
stock and barrel by K Street the Chamber
of Commerce the Business Roundtable the
Koch brothers and Wall Street so we know
one thing it's not going to be in favor
of the American middle class and
American working families and indeed
that is Ryan's that's his hallmark for
20 years in the house he works he works
for K Street so why the push to get this
through without a debate I mean it's
it's it seems like the Republicans could
win this debate if you look at all the
polling on it there's a lot of polling
Republicans basically on the side of the
administration on this question why not
run on it as you have reported you can
slice and dice the demographics any way
you want to and more people are
disgusted and appalled by the
deleterious and negative impact of
illegal immigration into this country
that's just simply the straightforward
facts but they can't even raise a voice
that is even remotely comparable to the
to the ownership of the the
establishment and global elites who are
demanding cheap labor of the and that's
straightforward it is the purpose their
purpose to bring more more immigration
into this country and to preserve lower
wages just just as president Trump has
wages rising the middle class is now
growing it was stagnant and declining
for 20 years until President Trump moved
into the Oval Office so you're saying
that the current Republican leadership
is willing to ignore the most basic
lesson of the last election and the
expressed will of the American
population in order to serve the
interests of a very small group of
people pay the bills absolutely and Ryan
is a lame-duck Speaker remember he will
only be in office until January of next
year but that's right he resigned but is
it's only the Republican Conference can
do in the House of Representatives he is
now enfranchised with the leadership of
the conference and what will almost
assuredly be a loss of 50 seats in the
midterm elections as a result of moving
into the amnesty abyss the base will not
stand for this for one minute no matter
how popular the president is and he's
wildly popular and no matter the
fictions that are spun up by Ryan and
his so-called leadership council where
they get is any do they have pollsters
who are telling them that politically
this is smart no they have they have
well-paid strategists telling them they
should run on the tax cuts rather than
the Trump agenda which is tax cuts
deregulation balancing international
trade creating jobs bringing back
manufacturing dealing with all of the
important issues in foreign policy
whether it is the the immense success of
the Singapore summit which is just one
of a litany of achievements of this
president unprecedented she
over the course of 16 months it is the
most mindless lemming like rush I've
ever seen even though they're rhinos to
absolute disaster
rhinos rushing like lemmings mindlessly
I love it
lou dobbs great to see you as always
thank mindlessly I admit was redundant
thanks great to be with the attack